hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and it's John over here so I still have
a ringing going on in my ear but I
wanted to do some spoiler talk about
thor ragnarok with J humphrey over here
main reason why is because people are
asking for it and since this is coming
out later than most people spoiler
review we're just gonna stick with
certain spoilers that we feel like yeah
this is something I would want to touch
on otherwise we'd be breaking down the
entirety of the movie you can dissect
pretty much every single scene and every
character in this and it's coming out
ledo not many people watch it so we'll
just keep it with just a few things that
really did stand out to us but before we
go into that I'm gonna give a shout out
to my girlfriend her name is little
friend Greg's girlfriend she gave me
this thor ragnarok poster from Kovac ha
hey I wanted a feature in the review but
like the [ __ ] boyfriend I am totally
forgot about it sorry babe
hope you still do pleasurable things to
me Ragnarok me in the bed you know and
I'm saying the only reason I want to do
the spoiler talk to is because I say in
our non spoiler that I have like nitpick
issues cuz these things didn't ruin the
film for me there's things I would have
liked to have seen the only real nip ik
I had was how they handled Thor's old
team and how they how they killed off
pretty much everyone except for the girl
she couldn't be around to be in the
movie she's not even there at all
because they're kind of just treated
like characters we were never supposed
to care about yeah there's sort of
dispatched on ceremoniously they both
take a couple of knives to the or so in
there I guess the reason why is because
I feel it's just really bad for the
actors for two movies and they were
pretty important characters especially
in the first Thor
they were very meaningful characters to
who Thor was and you never get to see a
scene where Thor learns about their
death you never not even their deaths
are treated like monumental deaths
they're treated more like alright yeah
hello kills some people we show that
hell is threatening and evil oh yeah
they really could have been anybody and
it kind of makes you wonder like why did
they need to kill them yeah why couldn't
they just if they didn't need to use the
for this movie one they just leave them
out of it you know or or put them over
here somewhere it's not like I was a
heavily invested in these guys screw
this movie yeah it's still it's still
I'm like it for these for those actors
who got cast in a Marvel movie who
weren't even one of the big players but
they were playing comic book characters
that I'm sure they were super excited to
be a part of I just felt really bad for
them they signed on before they knew
they wanted to course-correct this so I
you know I think it would be nice to
give me the actual moment to be like hey
you're not part of the new course
necessarily but we're gonna send you
yeah I'm gonna treated like we don't
really care about you yeah yeah instead
of giving them this sort of you could be
anybody except for the Asian guy you got
a little bit more of yeah yeah and
speaking of getting rid of characters
that who clearly marvel or take take
yeah Tiki Watts
yeah it's going what's doesn't care
about was getting rid of Natalie
Portman's character you know didn't mind
that I felt there should have been a
little bit more of a acknowledgement to
I get their rebranding Thor and they're
redefining it they're making it less
space opera Shakespearean thing yeah
serious yeah and more caning the whole
love story between Thor and Jane if you
follow any news articles it's pretty
obvious not only Portman doesn't like
being involved in the Marvel films I
feel like if anyone should have had a
monumental like let's write them out it
should have been the words old team it's
just kind of a funny line they had about
them breaking up and and didn't really
seem to have an impact on Thor when the
whole reason he seemed to care about
earth was because of Jane if you're
actually paying attention it is a little
perturbation yeah she's just not there
there's one line and that's about it and
you know given that we've spent two
movies on that romance I guess you like
we should tie it together somehow
yeah like sure that he was a little
heartbroken by it yeah that affected him
in any way yeah it's I mean cuz I've
heard the complaint by several people
being like there's too much comedy in
this film which I don't agree with I'm
like no I don't I don't think there's
too much comedy in this film if it's not
what you want
I get it I feel like that specific scene
when Loki and
are talking about them have them
breaking up but there should have been
at least a hint that it being
heartbreaking for him instead it is
there just a mutual breakup this is a
funny line you know the second time I
see the movie I'm sure that joke will
hit me different but but from here at
least yeah I'm like you know it would
have been nice to know if this affected
him anyway it seemed important at the
time I mean you know in two movies it
seemed important don't get me wrong I
don't really give a [ __ ] about Jay
actually when they were first they first
brought her up in the movie I didn't
even realize they were talking about
Jane I don't think I heard it yeah just
some random girl he was talking about
that he broke up with him look at it's
funny throw dated someone and I didn't
think talking about Jane and if there's
something I would have liked a little
more emphasis on or something to be
treated more strong I guess it would be
the villains you got essentially two big
villains of the Thor universe in here
you got searcher and hella and circular
kind of treated like a joke in the
beginning too and then he just sort of
shows up at the end and the way they
edited that trailer or made it look like
we're gonna get some epic fights who had
surgery but you do not get shot coming
at him is more than yeah it's a joke
we're hoax being kind of annoying and
just being a rageful monster well it
worked in the context of the film I
guess as an anticipation experience that
was a bit of a letdown to me yeah this
isn't gonna be the all-out brawl I was
expecting that looks like the craziest
moment like yeah what is that good it
looks like a Hellas unleashing surfer
this looks like her master plan is
unfolding and yeah it's and that even
that switcheroos is one that I'm a
little back and forth on that whole sort
of like wealth or can't really save the
day so he's just gonna let this big
giant guy like the prophecy be fulfilled
yeah yeah which on the one hand I
respect the choice in in a character
context Turman in a comic book movie I
kind of like the idea that the here goes
yeah this is a better idea instead of
going oh the way to to vite hella is
just to punch her a lot like a lot of
movies do you know I thought that was
kind of cool but at the same time you're
like oh so you guys are just gonna take
care of each other we're gonna get on
the ship yeah I like about what Marvel
does they're willing to destroy
established environments they destroyed
shield in Winter Soldier they destroy
as guard here the planet at least Asgard
the realm itself and I didn't mine
Asgard being destroyed they're more
willing to destroy places than they are
willing to kill characters yeah that's a
sacrifice in some way if anything I felt
the the feeling of Asgard being gone
more than any of the characters being
gone like Thor's team and J and B he
endured for so long yeah we've heard so
much now they're on a Star Trek
adventure yeah I did like hella a lot in
the film when she's on screen I did like
it there is that point though when Thor
gets the idea of o Banner left his ship
here we should break out pull off some
Great Escape mission here where you do
start to leave hella behind you kind of
you don't forget she's there because on
a car they're constantly bringing up
about hella so you don't forget about
her it just did bother me that her
effect does diminish because you've we
finally get to really spend more time
with her when they finally get back to
Asgard yeah you're like oh finale time I
could I use maybe a little bit more of
the fight the struggle because when we
cut back to Asgard and we see what he'll
is doing it's kind of you know standard
villain yeah yeah oh she's oppressing
people and having the people who are
hiding you know being persecuted by her
guards and stuff she's killing the
people I just thought the first half was
so well done with her you know when
she's like Google's everyone in Asgard
in an actual fight yeah okay like no
I'll do combat with all of you I'll take
out all the soldiers yeah that was a
great setup for villain territory like
you but she destroys Thor's hammer and
then she kills all the soldiers that was
so powerful because it really just
emphasized how the hell are they gonna
take this woman on I didn't mind them
getting rid of Thor's hammer I liked how
he he didn't feel like he gets to a
point where he doesn't need to penned on
it and he has an internal power being
the god of thunder which are really
emphasizing kudos to the trailers adding
in his eyeball yeah I was a good good
catch because I would have ruined a lot
yeah you know I could have used a little
more time spent learning like seeing how
he learns to you know walk in maneuver
again with only
depth perception you know I feel like
that's what this movie is really missing
there's one other element I would have
liked a little bit more something to be
treated just a tad bit more serious I
don't know if it's a deleted scene or I
don't know if they just didn't really
care to focus on it because they're
reinventing the whole tone and style
they probably wanted to steer clear away
from let's not repeat you know Thor
having sibling problems Loki and Thor
find out they have a sister yeah you
know and that mesda never really seemed
to be a thing for Thor I have a sister
and this is family and family is
important there's a reason he doesn't
kill Loki yeah because Loki's his bro
you know and yes he grew up with Loki so
there's a difference in dynamic there
knowing Thor how he is with his dad and
Loki and the people of Asgard I would
have expected him to try to get through
to her just a little bit in terms of who
Thor is I'm all for this new version of
Thor I love it I love it however there
seemed to be no sense of any
psychological troubling with him having
a sister yeah and they deal with that
and they do make a point through her to
show like ah Odin used to be a lot more
draconian and a lot more you know darkly
and probably the way she is cuz of Odin
yeah and it reveals things about him
who's you know the patriarch who's the
guy that clearly both Thor and Loki are
still you know looking up to and so
that's pretty big to drop on on
characters and yeah like I could have
used maybe some dealing with learning
the truth about your past yeah you know
especially yeah when it's a family issue
not only is the destruction of Asgard
coming but but my sister's doing it yeah
as I think the movie is fantastic yeah I
said in our non-spoiler review it's one
of my favorite MCU movies and I wouldn't
say there's too much comedy in it I just
think there should have been maybe five
to ten extra minutes devoted to a little
bit of trouble in certain situations
that's that's it that's all I really
care about yeah I just could have seen
it
I could have used a couple more scenes
where hellah is being truly diabolical
yeah you know like letting cuz I liked
cutting to her and watching her and
scourge kind of get to know each other I
thought that was cool but you know I
could have used a little more temperance
they're a little more reason to hate her
cuz I just kind of enjoyed watching her
yeah
and yeah maybe give the rest of the
movie I liked they they played with the
dynamics it wasn't just 100% comedy all
the way through they did to some quieter
moments some more
oh don't was specifically that moment
yeah yeah but you know especially with
the context and how much Ragnarok means
I could have used me out maybe a couple
more scenes just going oh man this is
serious right but ya know I really do
love this movie and it had a great time
a great time and I guess we'll call this
video are a few issues with thor
ragnarok spoilers and a few nitpicks
what issues did you have with thor
ragnarok independent subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
bell followed a Shawn Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram go check out our
patreon become a patron eject today jump
on it